reigning champion edward jones got off
to a rough start to begin the fall 2021
campaign amassing just eight grand prix
points will they rise to the occasion or
will they get buried in the standings
find out
now
up
me
uh
enterprise their main rivals as of late
uh joining them of course is worldwide
technology who had a strong showing in
week one i believe they came out with
the most points dardy business solutions
also joining us again as well as
ascension and bayer
the usuals are all back to compete again
this year and uh competing they are
again lots of drama in week one lots of
fun now if you watching at home happen
to be a part of a corporation in saint
louis we would love to have you join us
and you can do so by actually reaching
out to the email address which should be
popping up on your screen development st
louis chessclub.org those are the kind
people to get in touch with if you want
to join
the titans of the game that we see here
tonight
without further ado i believe the round
was slated to start at 6 15 so i'm going
to
start typing away over here see if i can
pull up some games see if we're actually
getting underway just yet
technology is taking on ascension edward
jones is up against bayer we have
enterprise against darty and then a
whole slew of extra matches of course
when two teams don't have the same
number of players everybody still gets
to play you just compete for board
points in the extra matches section
um okay so let's take a look
we've got uh yeah i'm honestly not sure
which matchup we should follow maybe we
should give edward jones their time in
the limelight once again see if they can
make a recovery from
the turbulent first week they had a lot
of forfeitures unfortunately a lot of
their players just couldn't make it and
i believe yeah their games are underway
so we're taking a look now at justini
linguini the mysterious newcomer to the
edward jones team uh of course
um
at 1800 uh he is i believe higher rated
than than even alex whose board i'm
gonna try to pull up now
um but yeah just to give you the rundown
of the alex jones team we have justine
linguini here we have alex curford we
have miquez we have paul frolin and we
have dn274
uh and they are up against bayer board
one for bay of course is now this is
just losing followed by m.c nick jm
uh followed by vindy followed by
alamaxia and finally with cross to pj
rounding out the
group there so board one justine
linguini let's get into the chess looks
like we're already on move 12 so let's
back up a little bit see how we got here
we had a queens gambit with two knight
f6 so not not my favorite variation to
be honest with you
um takes and then an early b4 so very
dangerous or early e4 very dangerous
stuff so knight b6
knight f3
uh and e6 so
yeah i think black has has gone pretty
wrong here if you want to play this uh
slightly off beat variation with two
knight f6 then definitely after e4 you
have to come back to knight f6 the
reason is after knight c3 you're gonna
break in the center with e5 and if you
manage to achieve that then you do get
to challenge uh white's big center but
after knight b6 we see knight f3 an
accurate move by justini keeping an eye
on this move e5 and now black will not
be able to challenge the big center and
white should have a pretty strong
advantage out of the opening
catching up with the players this is
where they're at currently and you can
already just sort of see on the board
the advantage that white has look at
these bishops and queen raking along
these open diagonals towards the black
king meanwhile the black pieces seem to
be stepping on each other's toes just a
little bit this bishop on d7 interferes
with the queen
this knights
would love to be on d5 but unfortunately
there's already another knight there and
lastly these rooks are also going to
have some trouble finding their way into
the game so good start for justini we'll
see if he is able to uh
to convert this into something real into
a material advantage
okay continuing on let's peek in on alex
kurford over here up against mcnick jim
um
which i don't i honestly don't know how
to pronounce this name he doesn't have
nearly enough vowels in his name but
we're going to go with something like
that
and here we have alex taking a pretty uh
conservative i wouldn't okay i wouldn't
say conservative approach but a pretty
compact approach he's keeping his pawns
further back in the center and even on
the queen side and king's side and
that's going to allow him to play a lot
more flexibly you know you're never sure
is black gonna play something like e5 d5
a5 as alex has now done you have to be
kind of ready for anything up against
these kinds of structures
um that being said white does enjoy the
space advantage at space advantage like
in the first game we see now knight a7
rook c8 so alex is trying to oh
yeah alex was putting on the pressure on
this b5 pawn pinning the c pawn to the
queen and i think white may have missed
this idea alex does capitalize and
that's just going to be an extra extra
pawn now for black and now things change
dramatically this knight is going to be
able to invade on these dark squares
black now will almost certainly break
with d5 at the right moment target the c
pawn and enjoy the extra pawn advantage
with uh
this a pawn on the queen side grabbing a
lot of space
okay let's continue on down uh looks
good for edward jones so far how is uh
miquez doing up against vindy so of
course uh nikes playing for edward jones
and vindy playing for
bayer here
and again it looks okay for white we
have a weird early night g5 idea
but i think this is happening because
black
wasn't sure how to develop this bishop
with such a cramped position
one option would have been to go with g6
and bishop g7 instead we see black
playing e6 here really drastically
challenging the center however you'll
notice white's king safely castled over
here on g1 black's king yet to be
castled still stuck in the center so
that's why white is spending some time
here to try and rip some some files and
some diagonals open against this black
king you know to my mind i so want to
take advantage of this king's position
that i would even play a move like e5
here just as much tension as possible
you want to rip open all these files and
and get this king before he can run away
knight g5 and it is a similar idea but
maybe not the best execution so
now it looks as though white had some
pressure got some threats can even give
a check potentially
but i believe
black is going to be able to escape with
this life here queen h6 but then maybe
bishop back to f8 is going to be
enough for black to complete development
meaning
this bishop might come out to g7 and
again
black is thrilled if he can he can just
castle here
you know the more i say it though
maybe vindy does have some some serious
pressure here and it's going to be tough
so vindy trying to keep his team afloat
with a good position up against miquez
playing for bayer once again all right
continuing on down we have paul frowan
on board four for edward jones let's
take a look up against alamaxia
and oh that's a g pawn that's just a g
pawn right there and don't even think
about saving your rook with bishop b5
because that knight is pinned that
bishop's undefended and alamaxia is also
off to a commanding start so what was
shaping up to be a blowout is now
looking pretty even uh with alamaxia
having the biggest advantage of all the
games we've looked at so far i would say
two of these games looking good for
edward jones but two of them looking
good for bayer bayer seems to be
excelling on the lower boards speaking
of lower boards there is just one more
in this match let's take a look at
dn274
up against crass to pj crasta pj is a
veteran of the corporate chess league
for sure
dn274 not a username i recognize uh but
then again i don't know many cyborgs um
okay
but what's going on in this position it
looks like white has pressure down this
h file and also has pressure up against
this knight on f6 now that's two
problems that black has to solve and he
only has one move to do it to do that
meanwhile material appears to be even
with
this doubled e pawn in exchange for this
f pawn and yeah black just castles queen
side giving up the knight if you want to
keep all your material you have to try
knight back to g8 here to stop the rook
h8 threats
but it's it's obviously not pretty
knight h8 queen h5 and i have to run
with my king but maybe i can stay
stay alive in that position it doesn't
look good but at least i'm not losing a
piece after castles the extra piece for
white should just be good so there it is
that's our ongoing drama edward jones
against bayer edward jones needs to win
some uh win some matches here tonight
they are far behind in the team
standings and if i know edward jones
they're they're going for the gold
tonight they're they're always going for
the gold
so let's uh stop now for a while slow
the pace down a little bit and stay with
justini linguini up against now this is
just losing here for a little bit uh
because i think this is a pretty high
level game for our corporate chess
league and justine has quite an
interesting position we see bishop h7
check here this is a
an interesting move
it's not often a move you see unless
white has a very concrete tactic to back
it up
why is that well you don't actually want
to leave your bishop on h7 for for too
long because if you do you know your
queen might get pushed away at some
moment and then your bishop's going to
be hanging so yeah expect bishop back to
g6 here now uh not leaving that bishop
on h7 for for too long
now the question is will white be able
to find a knockout punch or will black
find a way back into the game yeah
bishop e8 i i really like this move you
deal with the threat of knight f7
forking king and queen and at the same
time you're trading off some of these
really dangerous attackers
uh if i'm
uh white here i'm taking a moment to
figure out what to do just queen e4
though by just justini
so i imagine black will be happy to
trade off this these bishops but then
the knight is just going to jump in and
replace the bishop as an attacker we'll
have to play something like king g8 to
follow and then
you